What are stigma? 80 most Netties,
which means orders. I'm ready.
My home has been in ancient Greek.
Hello world.
It's Saroj and Coobernetti's is an open
source project that enables developers
to automates the process of deploying,
scaling,
and managing containerized apps.
That's right.
Not just any kind of apps specifically
containerized that by the way,
if you want to be notified when my
weekly tutorial videos are released,
hit the subscribe button.
I'll of course explain what
containerized means. In fact,
we'll go through the three steps
necessary to make this happen.
We'll create a cloud
environment for our application.
Using Google cloud will build and
containerize an image classifier APP.
Then we'll deploy our app to the
cloud using the power of Kubernetes,
and this same process works for
any kind of APP, email services,
social networks on APP that raises $1
million just to send Yoda people literally
anything is possible. Really any kind
of APP. A container is a lightweight,
standalone executable package of a
piece of software that has everything
necessary to run it.
Code runtime system tools,
system libraries and settings.
It wraps up everything on APP needs,
not just the code, but all
the dependencies, libraries,
and configurations.
It abstracts away from any of the
environments, physical or virtual needs,
which it will run on.
That means containerized
apps run consistently across
environments from Dev to
test,
to prod from a local machine to a cloud
instance without the need for retooling.
Nowadays,
users expect Apps to be available 24
seven and developers expect to deploy new
versions of these apps
several times a day.
Containerization helps package
software to reach these goals,
enabling apps to be released an
updated in an easy and fast way without
downtime.
Over the past few years,
developers have come to rely on container
technology to increase the portability
of their code and ensure that their apps
run consistently across a variety of
platforms.
They enable a much shorter deployment
time and improved APP or liability for 51
research predicts the APP container market
will approach two point $7 billion in
2020 up from a projected
1.5 billion in 2018 not bad.
Considering that containers only started
to become popular five years ago with
the release of a popular open
source project called docker.
Docker was the first to package Linux
kernel features together in a way that
allowed teams to create artifacts easily.
They could run on different servers
and it's now become a household name.
Docker containers made it so much easier
for developers to enjoy parody between
each of their environments.
They could run the same exact
container image across all them.
Instead of building out an entire
server to run a service or an APP,
just run a docker container image on a
host and it will use a smaller amounts of
that host's resources to run the APP.
Compared to traditional
virtual machine images,
containers are lightweight and ephemeral.
They can be spun up and spun down as
resources increased or decreased or as the
APP scales in the age of cloud
architectures and increasingly distributed
computing environments,
docker has seen very
rapid adoption these days.
Docker has become synonymous with the
container technology at its core. In fact,
you might even hear a developer say docker
when they're really just referring to
containers. In general. I
dockerized that using mezzos you,
you did what a problem arose though
early adopters of docker found that they
were soon running hundreds or even
thousands of workloads inside these
containers. This quickly became
an operational challenge.
If you have a few
containers and a few apps,
orchestrating them isn't too complicated,
but with thousands of
containers and services,
it definitely gets complicated.
Enter Coobernetti's Kubernetes is one
of the highest velocity projects in open
source history.
It was first developed as an internal
tool in the go programming language at
Google.
Then later made open source as a tool
for any developer to use for container
orchestration.
Kubernetes is a tool for automating the
deployment management and scaling of
containerized apps.
It makes the ongoing orchestration of
potentially thousands of containers
manageable and helps ensure
your app is always running.
Coubernetties is becoming to orchestration
as docker has become to containers,
as Microsoft has become to open
source somehow pretty much synonymous.
Think of docker and Kubernetes as two
significant pieces of a larger system.
Docker will containerize
your APP. COOBERNETTI's.
We'll automate it's pipeline.
Let's go over some of the fee
concepts in Coobernetti's. First,
a container is the smallest unit it has.
The whole point of Kubernetes is to
manage, deploy, and monitor containers.
These could be docker containers,
but any kind of containers work.
A node is the host that
the container runs on.
A pod is a management unit
in Coobernetti's comprise
of one or more containers.
Each pod has a unique IP
address in storage namespace.
All containers share these
networking and storage resources.
We use a Yammel file to define
a pod Yammel, by the way,
since for yet another markup language.
I love that.
The file extension is literally a mean.
This Yammel file contains pod attributes
like any med at metadata or the API
version. Then there's deployment. When
a pod is deleted, it's gone for good,
but with deployment,
Kubernetes ensures that number of pods
that are user specifies is always up and
running in the system.
A deployment,
we'll specify how many
instances of a pod we'll run.
We again use a Yammel file to define
this deployment with instructions. Oh,
and there's one more Yammel file
that's used. It helps define a service.
A service is an abstraction that defines
a local set of pods and a policy by
which to access them.
Sometimes called a microservice.
A service is connected to a deployment
via the label attributes. In this case,
the label is Ngi and ECS.
Kubernetes depends on these Yamille files
to check if the desired pod deployment
or service is running as defined.
The overall architecture of
Kubernetes has three main components,
master nodes, worker nodes in
a distributed key value store.
The master node is the entry point for
all administrative tasks related to
managing the Kubernetes cluster.
The master node has an API server,
a scheduler that schedules
casks to worker nodes.
It controller manager that watches
the desired state of the objects.
It manages and watches their current
state throughout the API server.
If the current state of an object
doesn't meet the desired states,
then the control loop takes corrective
steps to ensure the current state is the
same as the desired states and
one more a key value store.
It stores the cluster state
and configuration details.
It also uses a special consensus
mechanism to let multiple servers agree on
these values.
There's more to Coopernetti's,
but that's it for a high level overview.
Now let's use Kubernetes to help deploy
an image classifier web API that anyone
can use. Three steps here. We'll
create our environment on Google cloud.
Then we'll use the care os library to
build a deep neural network for image
classification.
Package it inside of a web app using
flask and containerize it with docker.
Lastly, we'll deploy this
container using Coobernetti's.
We'll first start a virtual
machine on Google cloud.
We just need to select compute engine.
Then create an instance.
Let's keep it small for this demo.
Once we set some details,
we'll click create to launch an
instance to set up our environment.
Now for step two,
building an image classifier.
If we open up a terminal and the browser,
we can connect to our newly created
virtual machine in the cloud.
We can go ahead and install docker,
then start it up.
Once docker is running will containerize
an existing deep convolutional neural
network built in chaos.
I have a very detailed
video on how convolutional
networks work to help classify
images,
see the link in the video description,
but in order for our code to run
inside of a docker container,
we'll need to create a
requirement's dot txt file,
which will contain all the packages
are code needs to run. That way,
no matter where we ship
our docker container,
the server will be able to
install our codes dependencies.
Then we'll create a docker file so
docker will know how to build and run our
project. We can build our docker
container in a single line,
then run it with our model running. We can
easily test it. Let's give it an input,
a photo of a dog, and it will classify
it by returning. It's breed. Boom,
Shakalaka homie instance.
Api builtin python served with
flask and wrapped in docker.
Now we can deploy this
container to Coobernetti's.
First we'll create a docker hub account.
We're going to instruct Coobernetti's to
install our container from a centrally
host server docker hub. We'll log
into docker hub from command line,
tag our container,
then push our container to docker hub.
Now in Google cloud will
select Coobernetti's engine,
create a new Coubernetties cluster and
then connect to the cluster using the
cloud shell.
We can now run our docker container in
Coobernetti's the image tag points to our
hosted docker image on docker hub.
Lastly,
we'll expose our pod on port 80 to the
outside world once it's running and test
out our APP by running a rest command
pointing to our Coubernetties cluster
success,
we just created a scalable
image classifier API that
anyone can access on the
web.
Moving forward,
we can explore all the different scaling
and management features that Kubernetes
has, but that's too much for this
one video. Three things to remember.
Coobernetti's is an open source project
that enables developers to automate the
process of deploying,
scaling,
and managing containerized
apps on a cluster of machines.
Containers enable a much
shorter deployment time and
improved APP reliability by
including required runtime
resources along with app code,
and we can use a combination of python,
docker,
and Kubernetes to create a reliable
and scalable web app pretty easily.
What's currently your
favorite devops tool?
Share it with me in the comments section
if you want to stay updated on my
weekly programming tutorials,
it subscribed,
and for now I've got to look into
Cuba flow, so thanks for watching.